to some other developing news now zayn
collins the star
unlv basketball recruit accused of
causing a crash that took the life of 52
year old erica chavarria
has been formerly formally rather
charged with dui
and reckless driving that crash happened
last wednesday on fort apache right near
blue diamond
our hector mejia was in court earlier
this morning and has some new
information
on the dui charges
today we learned zeon collins tested
positive for marijuana and was above the
legal limit the day of the crash
he hired high profile attorneys who
appeared on his behalf this morning
collins was released from jail last week
on the highest level of monitoring
in a written statement attorneys david
chastanov and richard shanfield said
quote
zayon maintains his innocence and is
entitled to a fair and just
court process in determining all of the
circumstances of the accident
his case will be decided by the rule of
law and not by media speculation
or emotional reactions collins is
charged with felony dui resulting in
death
and reckless driving investigators say
the 19 year old was the driver of a
dodge
challenger that slammed into another car
killing 52-year-old
eric echeverria according to collins
attorney
he did not have to pay bail to get
released on december 31st
court records show he is required to
stay out of trouble
he's not allowed to drive and must stay
away from alcohol and drugs
collins reportedly told investigators
the other vehicle turned
in front of him this is home
surveillance video sent to 8 news now
of the crash the arrest report revealed
that data taken from the dodge
charger shows it was traveling at
approximately 88 miles per hour
in a 35 miles per hour zone two seconds
before the crash
the next court hearing is scheduled for
february 17th
reporting in downtown las vegas hector
mejia 8 news now